Hello friends and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes Countdown the official
celebration for Pride may only last a
month but with more and more great
movies centered around the lgbtq plus
Community coming every single year the
real movement never stops and to help
keep that celebration going is our list
of the best lgbtq Plus movies by Tomato
Meter right now on Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
[Music]
starting with number 10 blue is the
warmest color
this 2013 French drama is based on the
2010 graphic novel of the same name it
follows a teenager played by Adele
exarchopolis who forms a strong
connection with an older aspiring
painter played by Leia sidhu
h
this is
and then
both lead actresses received warm
receptions or should I say blue warm
receptions for this certified fresh film
which unanimously won the Palm Door from
the official jury at the Cannes Film
Festival now critics love this one too
obviously with a consensus that calls it
raw honest powerfully acted and
deliciously intense how's that for an
impressive grouping of adjectives
number nine love Simon
this film marked the first mainstream
Studio released teen rom-com with a gay
lead character it was directed by Greg
berlante best known as a driving force
behind CW shows like Riverdale The Flash
and Batwoman this fresh Shake on the
coming of age story follows 17 year old
Simon played by Nick Robinson who's
falling in love with an anonymous
classmate online and is yet to tell his
family and friends that he's gay and
when he and his dad played by Josh
schumel do finally have the discussion
it is a beautiful thing how long have
you known
13 four years four years it
eating dinner together four years ago in
the movies together I'm sorry
all the stupid jokes
I know I didn't mean him
I just want you to know that I love you
I wouldn't change anything about you
and he stopped crying I'm trying I'm
trying
oh God
love Simon which by the way has a
spin-off series called love Victor on
Hulu also Stars Jennifer Garner as
Simon's mom plus a great young cast
along with Robinson that includes
Catherine Langford and Keenan Lonsdale
the latter of which was inspired to
publicly come out through his
involvement in the film
number eight Carol
this movie is set in 1950s Manhattan and
follows a forbidden Affair between a
young female photographer and an older
woman who's going through a tough
divorce it has a star-studded cast that
includes names like Sarah Paulson Jake
Lacy and Kyle Chandler which is
impressive already but even more so with
Cate Blanchett and Rooney Mara
brilliantly leading the way
played It For You on piano at your house
now remember
thank you oh God don't I'm not afraid
you do not you look wonderful
stay like that
do you miss Richard
I don't know I haven't thought about him
all day
if you didn't know Carol is based on the
1952 romance novel the price of Salt by
Patricia Highsmith later repubbed as
Carol in 1990 and repub names were
published I learned that two seconds ago
and it was directed by Todd Haynes a
pioneer of an early 90s filmmaking
movement known as New queer Cinema now
the critics consensus for this certified
fresh hit is that it lives up to the
source material thanks in part to quote
Deft direction from Haynes
number seven the power of the dog
Benedict Cumberbatch stars in this one
as a successful and frightening Rancher
named Phil he forms a roller coaster
relationship with the son of a widow
played by Kirsten Dunst after she
marries Phil's Brother played by Jesse
plemons who happens to be her husband in
real life
I wonder
what little lady made these
actually I did Sir
my mother was a florist
so I made them to look like the ones in
our garden
oh well do pardon me
yeah
they're Justice
real as possible
written and directed by the
oscar-winning Jane Campion the power of
the dog is based on the 1967 novel of
the same name by Thomas Savage which
Campion said was optioned at least five
times before she was actually finally
able to get the film made but that
wasn't until its original Stars
Elizabeth Moss and Paul Dano were
replaced after delays in production the
film certified fresh Tomato Meter score
is sitting nicely next to a strong
audience score with many reviews from
said audience praising it for quote
great acting and interesting ideas
number six call me by your name
this coming-of-age drama was directed by
Luca guaranino and is set in Northern
Italy in 1983 where a romantic
relationship forms between 17 year old
Elio played by Timothy chalamet and a 24
year old American grad student named
Oliver played by Army Hammer Oliver is
living with Elio's family for the summer
as he works under Elio's father an
archeology professor and I gotta tell
you this is where my shalomania started
foreign
you must be exhausted a little bit come
come come this film wraps up what is
known as Luca guadalino's desire Trilogy
and it was nominated for Best Picture
Oscar while the script which was written
by James Ivory and based on Andre
ossiman's 2007 novel the same name I
feel like there's a lot of things based
on novels of the same name it actually
brought home the Oscar for adapted
screenplay now on top of that 22 year
old chalamet my favorite became the
third youngest best actor nominee in
Oscar's history for his performance and
the guy learned a third language from
this movie like really man what is there
anything you can't do
okay so we're halfway there and we've
already looked at some seriously good
movies which movie is going to be number
one on this list any guesses I'll wait
for you guys to answer psych we gotta
keep going
five pain and Glory
Tonio Banderas I always feel like I have
to say the name that way stars in the
Spanish drama is an aging Spanish film
director who's going through a bit of a
creative crisis aren't we all now this
forces him to look back on some of the
more memorable events and people of his
past
foreign
he too
no
pain and Glory which also features
Penelope Cruz in a supporting role was
actually chosen by Time Magazine as the
best movie of 2019 and the certified
fresh offering was a film festival and
award circuit darling resulting in Oscar
Critics Choice and Golden Globe
nominations for Banderas who actually
won a few things too at places like the
Cannes Film Festival
number four tangerine
this dramedy tells the story of a
transgender sex worker who finds out her
pimp slash boyfriend has been cheating
on her the film was directed and
co-written by Sean Baker and is perhaps
known for being shot using just three
iPhone 5S smartphones equipped with just
a video app and an adapter or two oh man
the 5S talk about the memories now the
cash they saved on camera equipment was
used to pay extras and for shooting
locations like this one
all right that's enough let him go
what's going on this fight this attacked
me he held me money
is this true no you don't even know her
get out of my car she just attacked me
so a random woman just grabs you and
starts yes yes check the pulse
Alexander girl what the you know I
don't do that I don't know what's what's
happening he owes me money
forty dollars I don't even know her why
is he owe you 40. very well
asked him Tangerine was executive
produced by the duplos brothers and has
been a big hit with critics who say it
quote shatters casting conventions and
is a pretty wonderful old-fashioned
comedy at heart number three book smart
this 2009 film stars Caitlin Dever and
beanie Feld seen as two High School
academic Superstars trying to cram four
years of fun into one night before
graduating that's aggressive and yes
kids make sure that you can hear me that
means breaking some rules every now and
then get to go to a party tonight
what let's go to Nick's party are you
kidding no no way we only have one night
left to have studied and partied in high
school otherwise we're just gonna be the
girls that missed out we haven't done
anything we haven't broken any rules
okay
we've broken a lot of rules one we have
fake IDs fake college ID so we can get
into their 24-hour Library name one
person whose life was so much better
because they broke a couple of rules
Picasso yes he broke art rules name a
person who broke a real rule Rosa Parks
Susan B Anthony
now this marks a directorial debut of
Olivia Wilde who picked up the
independent Spirit Award for best first
feature boom plus it was a surprise hit
at the box office with nearly 25 million
dollars made on a six million dollar
budget math and with a Supporting Cast
it includes Jessica Williams Lisa Kudrow
Will Forte and Jason Sudeikis critics
love book smart for being quote
fast-paced funny and fresh adding a
smart new Spin To The Coming of Age
comedy number two portrait of a lady on
fire
I don't know what number one is but I
gotta tell you this is my favorite of
all time this period piece set in 1760
France is about a female artist
commissioned to paint the wedding
portrait of a young woman who has just
left the convent as they go to an
isolated island to have the painting
done the two begin to form an intimate
relationship
s
foreign
along with highlighting the Timeless
ongoing lgbtq struggle this film is also
pro-feminist as it features only a
handful of short dialogue lines spoken
by men portrait of a lady on fire is
certified fresh at 97 on the Tomato
Meter and earned nominations at the
independent Spirit Critics Choice and
Golden Globe awards for best foreign
language film among many other honors
and accolades in part because as the
critics say it quote finds stirring
thought-provoking drama within a
powerfully acted Romance
number one moonlight
directed by Barry Jenkins this film
tells the heartbreaking story of a young
black man who grapples with his identity
and sexuality told across three defining
chapters in his life with three actors
Alex Hibbert Ashton Sanders and toronte
Rhodes telling the story the film
explores the challenges Chiron faces
including the emotional and physical
abuse he endured growing up and it also
showcases the kindness and support from
those around him including a father
figure character played by mahershala
Ali
that's why I gonna call you
blue
say your name blue
at some point you gotta decide for
yourself
can't let nobody make that decision for
you with critics calling it a quote
remarkable and brilliantly crafted look
at lives too rarely seen in cinema
Moonlight is the first lgbtq and the
first film featuring an all black cast
to win the Academy Award for best
picture it also won for adapted
screenplay and mahershala Ali picked up
a best supporting actor Oscar for his
performance as well and sure this film
was in the middle of a major Oscars Club
courtesy of Warren Beatty but it should
be remembered for just how impactful and
Powerful it truly is well my friends
there you have it our list of the best
lgbtq Plus movies and of course I'm sure
you know this list is much longer than
10 films and I highly recommend that you
check out our full list and all the
great options we have at
rottentomatoes.com my personal favorite
is the watermelon woman directed by
Cheryl Dunya iconic but thanks for
checking out today's list until next
time I'm your host Naz Perez we'll see
you back here for more Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
[Music]
thank you